foreign
[Music]
my name is Tim Looney I'm the senior
director of immunology and
bioinformatics at singular genomics
we're a Next Generation sequencing
company
and today I'm going to talk to you about
ways in which we've been working to
improve Next Generation sequencing
through Innovations in chemistry and
engineering
so the outline of my talk is as follows
I I'm going to start by highlighting the
current challenges in NGS both for
research and clinical use
and there I'm going to highlight the
importance of fast flexible sequencing
to reduce turnaround time
in the in the second part of my talk I'm
going to switch and and provide an
overview of the sequencing by synthesis
process and along the way I'll describe
uh the the Innovations we've made to
enable rapid SBS
and then the last portion of this
presentation I'm going to describe
applications of Rapid SBS and they're
all I'll provide data from the new
singular genomics G4 platform
so to get things started uh you know
before we decided to build the G4
platform we we wanted to understand that
the current pain points in NGS and
specifically the the factors
contributing to Long turnaround time
and so we we talked to a number of NGS
users both in the clinical and research
space
and ask them about things uh such as the
time required for Library preparation
delays owing to the batching of samples
the time spent on sequencing itself and
then in the case of the clinical
applications the time spent on analysis
and interpretation
and the results of that study uh is
presented in this slide
so at the top for clinical applications
where the turnaround time is roughly one
to two weeks we found that batching
related delays and the time for
sequencing itself were the primary
contributors to the turnaround time
now for for research applications where
the turnaround time was up to four weeks
batching by far uh is a primary
contributor to to turn around time
so so this was interesting but I think
it's useful to to take a look at these
trends at an application specific level
and and look at the the turnaround time
requirements for each NGS application
so in this slide I've partitioned a
number of NGS applications based on the
the required turnaround time
so at the left we have the Urgent
priority applications and here every
hour counts uh and the turnaround is
largely dictated by the by the time
required for sequencing and Analysis
so this is an example where any
technology that can improve or increase
the speed of sequencing can have a
direct positive impact on testing
now as one moves to the right to the
high priority uh applications uh
batching related delays but also the
time for sequencing our importance and
I'll note within this this subset of
applications there's a potential for for
some gating to to be related to the
availability of the clinician
and then moving further to the right to
the moderate priority activities this
includes things like early cancer
screening but also various research
applications and here turnaround time is
by far the greatest contributor excuse
me batching uh is by far the greatest
contributor to turnaround time and if we
look at the research applications
themselves we can we can understand why
the read Requirements for the research
applications can vary tremendously
so something for example like single
cell rna-seq or high c
may require a billion reads per sample
whereas a targeted application like
immune repertoire sequencing may require
in the millions of reads so in order to
address those batch related delays one
really needs to have flexible throughput
and then on the far right the low
priority
long-term studies
these studies are primarily motivated by
the cost of sequencing and and accuracy
so so from this we we really took home
the point that speed is required
especially for the for the clinical
applications but flexibility uh in
throughput is important for both
clinical and research applications
so now I want to switch to describe the
sequencing by synthesis process and the
ways in which we've been working to
improve it to enable rapid SBS
and I just want to underscore that as we
approach the SBS process and and sought
to improve it we really took home the
the Lessons Learned in that uh first
portion of my talk where I uh discussed
the importance of the fast flexible
sequencing
so I want to start by giving an overview
of the sequencing by synthesis process
and and actually what I'm going to
describe is uh Optical Ensemble
sequencing by synthesis using
fluorescently labeled reversible
terminated nucleotides
this is the most common uh approach for
SBS it's used by companies like Illumina
and uh and singular genomics
and here one starts with input DNA
comprising a library those input DNA
molecules are exposed to a flow cell
where they're attached to the flow cell
in a process called templating or
seeding
after the the DNA molecules are
templated they they are then clustered
to create copies uh and each cluster May
consist of hundreds to thousands of
copies of those original template
molecules
now each cluster will end up giving rise
to a single sequencing read and that's
why this process is termed Ensemble
sequencing
in The Next Step the sequencing occurs
and this is achieved through the use of
fluorescently labeled nucleotides that
have been blocked and those nucleotides
are incorporated into complementary
strands
complementary strands through the use of
a polymerase and because they're blocked
only a single nucleotide will
incorporate
uh after after that
an image is taken of the flow cell to
determine which nucleotide incorporated
into each cluster
and then and then finally there's a
cleavage step to remove the linger
between the fluorophore and the
nucleotide and that blocking yd and the
process may be repeated
and and this uh this process is referred
to as a cycle
and each cycle will reveal one base of
the template molecules and historically
it's been a slow process anywhere
between five to ten minutes uh is
typical but in our hands owing to a
number of uh Innovations which which
I'll go into discuss in detail we've
been able to get this to under three
minutes and actually I think that in the
near term uh as low as 90 second Cycles
could be possible
now following the image acquisition one
needs to convert the images to fastq
files uh and then and then finally those
fast few files containing the reads can
be interpreted and that can include
things like aligning to the genome uh
calling variants
processing the
um the the abundance of different RNA
transfers
so with this overview now I want to turn
and describe each step in in Greater
detail
so starting with the templating and
clustering there are two types of flow
cells that one can use at this step the
first is called an unpatterned flow cell
and with this approach uh the the flow
cell enables templating and clustering
throughout the flow cell surface uh so
that the Clusters may arise randomly
across the flow cell surface
and uh as a constant I would say that
firstly that one of the benefits of the
on pattern flow cell is the simplicity
uh but uh the the drawbacks are owing to
that random distribution of clusters in
some cases the the Clusters are too
close to one another to enable clear
Imaging and that reduces the quality and
then another issue
overgrown clusters which are larger than
the others and and uh and can also uh
reduce the the quality and throughput
so so only to these limitations that the
field has has generally shifted to
pattern flow cells shown at the bottom
and here the templating and seating is
is contains is constrained to Define
spots across the flow cell surface
this enables even cluster sizes and and
further by controlling the distance
between spots one can precisely tune the
throughput of the flow cell
so owing to those advantages uh we we
use pattern flow cells in in the G4
so so then the next step is uh uh the
nucleotide incorporation the Imaging and
the cleavage and here I have a cartoon
of a polymerase with an elongating
Strand and the template strand which is
bound to the flow cell surface and
you'll note that the floor the the
nucleotides are each labeled by a
separate fluorophore so four colors and
four nucleotides this is referred to as
four color chemistry and the use of Four
Color chemistry facilitates Downstream
signal interpretation resulting in
higher quality uh sequencing and so for
that reason we use for color chemistry
another thing I want to point out is the
Linker between the fluorophore and the
nucleotide
so that the Linker needs to be stable
but it also needs to enable rapid
cleavage following incorporation and
imaging so this this is very important
if one is to uh to achieve rapid SPS
it's something we worked on a lot
and it's further important because rapid
rapid cleavage also ensures that uh that
defacing is is is minimized and
dephasing refers to a phenomenon where
the template molecules maybe come out of
sync and that that um reduces the the
quality of the resulting reads
and now another point that I'd like to
mention is is that even the spacing and
the orientation between the nucleotide
and the fluorophore can impact
performance and the reason is that these
modified nucleotides must enter the
polymerase active site and be
incorporated into the elongating Strand
and that can be affected by the 3D
structure of the nucleotide here's
another place where we spent a lot of
time
identifying a great solution
and then uh likewise with the with the
optimization of the nucleotides one must
also optimize the polymerase itself
and because this the polymerase is uh
tasked with incorporating uh unnatural
nucleotides
polymerase engineering is required to
achieve rapid incorporation with minimal
misincorporation
and then the last point I want to
mention uh regards to the accessibility
of the template strand it must be
accessible to the polymerase in order to
enable efficient incorporation of the
labeled nucleotides
and that results in brighter clusters
and in general there's an inverse
relationship between cluster brightness
and imaging time so the brighter the
Clusters the shorter the Imaging time
required and again this is another place
where
optimization is needed to get to that
under three minute cycle that I
mentioned
great so now I want to turn to the base
calling and the downstream
interpretation uh so here the key tasks
are to process the images acquired
during that that those sequencing cycles
and that has to incur at the same time
that um the the sequence
is
time processing that must occur rapidly
and after the fastview files are
generated then they must also be
interpreted and that's in a lot it often
involves computationally intensive tasks
like alignment and variant detection and
so this is a challenging problem on the
slide at the right side you can note an
image of a pattern flow cell and just
want to convey that these are large
images and
in order to do this rapidly one needs to
carefully consider the hardware uh
needed to accelerate these tasks so in
this next slide I want to describe that
the hardware the the main Hardware
options and what we've decided to go
with
so the first type of circuit relevant to
this task is called an fpga or field
programmable gate array this is a type
of configurable integrated circuit which
can enable application specific
acceleration
and one of the the big benefits of an
fpga is the low power consumption so
it's good for things like mobile devices
and in fact fpga was one of the first
approaches to accelerate some
bioinformatics tasks
the downside to fpga is that's a very
difficult to program so it can take a
lot of time to accelerate an arbitrary
piece of software
now the second type of relevant circuit
is a GPU or Graphics processing unit
this is the type of circuit that was
originally designed to accelerate uh
manipulation of images but it's since
been used for a variety of computing
tasks and what's interesting here is
that the GPU processing power has
increased tremendously in recent years
it's actually surpassed Moore's Law and
you can note that uh in the graph to the
to the right of this slide
and then the third the third type of
relevant circuit is a central processing
unit CPU this is a highly versatile uh
circuit it's the heart of a computer and
although the the growth and power of
CPUs is now less than Moore's Law
recently multi-core designs have emerged
that it enabled multi-threading up to
hundreds of threads per CPU and so that
greatly enhances the versatility
and so uh I'll link to the the advances
in CPU and GPU power uh that combination
is a very attractive approach for for uh
this Downstream image analysis and
interpretation and in fact in our hands
uh you know I think a 30-minute
turnaround time is possible to analyze a
whole 30X genome using an integrated GPU
CPU solution
and the last point I want to mention
about the GPU CPU approach is the
availability of those resources in the
cloud they have excellent availability
in the cloud which enables one to to
easily
transfer and accelerated workflow to the
cloud to run at scale
and the last thing I want to mention in
this portion of the talk is this uh is
how to achieve flexible throughput uh
and there are two main ways that one can
accomplish this the the first is through
the use of multiple flow cell types each
having a different uh read capacity
and the second is through the use of
enabling multiple flow cells per run
and in the case of the G4 platform we've
taken both approaches so we have a an F2
flow cell producing 150 million reads
and an F3 flow cell producing 300
million reads in addition to this the
the G4 includes four flow cell ports so
up to four flow cells may be loaded at
runtime there's an image of the flow
cells on the right and I'll further note
that each flow cell contains four
fluidically independent Lanes to
facilitate multiplexing
so so with this strategy we can deliver
uh flexible throughput from 150 million
reads up to 1.2 billion reads per run
great so so now I'd like to in this last
part of the talk I'd like to discuss the
applications of Rapid SVS and and here I
want to highlight data from the new
singular genomics G4 platform
and I want to say uh uh if before I show
you the data uh you know we approached
this uh the sequencing in uh first to
deliver faster more flexible sequencing
but we also wanted to do so without any
compromise to sequence quality and so I
hope to convey to you in this section
how we've accomplished that
and and to start uh I'd like to show you
some rna-seq data because that's that's
a very common application and then after
that I'll switch to whole genome
sequencing
so here is an uh overview of a study
that we performed uh using rna-seq to
evaluate the technical representability
of the G platform
we prepared a poly arnac Library using
the reference sample uhr with an ercc
spike in to assess the accuracy over a
over a wide dynamic range and this was
uh performed as part of a larger RNA
rnac study that we're going to assume
publish
and the sequencing following Library
preparation the the sequencing was
performed on two separate G4 instruments
using an F2 flow cell and two by hundred
base pair reads and after uh the
sequencing the uh the reads were
downsampled to 200 to 25 million reads
uh per sample
and following that transcripts were
Quantified using star and salmon
so in the in the lower left of this
slide I have a a table uh highlighting
the high level run metrics so one can
note that the q30 percentage q30 for
both read one and read two of the two
replicates is above 85 percent
and then if we turn to the upper right
hand corner of the slide we have the
correlation between observed counts for
the ercc spike in versus the expected
counts and and we see a high correlation
for both replicate 1 and replica 2 with
results that are that are quite similar
across the technical replicates
and uh below we have a correlation of
transcript counts across the two
replicas and here again a very high
correlation
0.995 suggesting that the platform has
excellent technical reproducibility
but but you know I I think in in a
really interesting question is is to ask
how this data compares to the data uh
produced by uh a more conventional SBS
platform and so what we did to address
that is to take the same uh input
material uhr with ercc and and submit it
for sequencing through a third party uh
with the next seek 2000 and then we took
that data and compared it to to the the
uh the sequencing performed on the G4
and here are the results of that
comparison
so taking a look at the upper left the
correlation of transcript counts between
the Illumina and G4 replica technical
replica one we see again a high
correlation in transcript counts 0.993
and I'll note that the correlation
across platforms is nearly the same as
the correlation of technical replicates
within platform so I think that that
speaks to the fact that the data is
quite similar across these two platforms
and and consistent with with one what
one might expect from this high
correlation in transcript counts we we
also see very similar profiles of Gene
body coverage uh below and then in the
middle the number of detected genes
across both data sets and then uh the
finally the distribution of reads across
genic and intergenic regions
so so I think this is encouraging that
despite the speed UPS in in the
sequencing process the data quality is
is quite good uh but perhaps a more
rigorous examination of of the data
quality would would be one that involves
variant detection uh following quality
genome sequencing
so to it to address that we decided to
sequence the the na12878 reference cell
line
uh using two by 150 base pair reads and
we did this using four F2 flow cells
Each of which produce 150 million reads
uh and and thereby produce uh about 700
million two by 150 base pair of reads
total
so taking a look at the bottom left the
metrics four flow cells
the the percentage q30 for read 1 and V2
from each of those flow cells and again
here you'll see the q3d scores in the
high 80s to low 90s
now if we took it take a look at the
upper right hand uh of this slide we can
we can note the quality score
distributions across read one and read
two very similar quality score
distribution suggesting that there's not
a a difference in quality between read
one and read two of the Paradigm beads
then moving below the observed versus
predicted quality this this plot shows
how how well calibrated the quality
scores are and we see excellent
concordance between the observed and
predictive quality and I think this this
highlights one of the strengths of the
platform that the quality scores are are
quite accurate
great now now I'd like to touch on uh on
coverage so reads were aligned to the
genome with bwa and then we assessed the
the coverage over high confidence
regions of of the genome and here you
can note uh the at the top metrics when
using two flow cells uh or 20x Target
coverage three free flow cells which is
30X Target coverage and then the entire
four flow cell data is set 40x Target
coverage and the 40x target coverage
achieved a 45x mean coverage over the
genome with 99.69 of bases covered at
greater than 10x
and then at the bottom left we have the
observed versus theoretical coverage as
expected from a possum process and we
can see here again that that there's a
great uh consistency between the two
suggesting that uh there is even
coverage
and then moving to the right
the normalized coverage as a as a
function of the GC contents
and one to note that there's even
coverage over a broad range of GC
content there there is a modest
reduction in coverage as one goes to the
extremely high GC but it's it's not
anything uh out of the ordinary from
what has been reported in literature
and then on the right a circus plot
giving the global view of the results
the innermost ring shows the coverage
across the chromosomes and then the
middle ring uh the GC contents
uh so so this is encouraging uh but but
I think uh really that one of the best
ways to evaluate the data is to assess
the accuracy of the reads following
alignment and so this slide uh does that
very thing I think it's a quite an
important slide
so on the left uh we have the accuracy
of read one and read two as a function
cycle and this is showing for each of
the four flow cells in the study
uh one to note the height accuracy over
a broad uh
over or over the entire read uh moreover
the accuracy uh profiles for read one
and read two look quite similar and so I
think again this speaks to the fact that
read one and read two uh with this
Paradigm sequencing approach are are
quite similar in quality
and then on the right we have uh the
error rate broken down by error mode
and and here one can note that the error
the errors are are dominated by
substitution sequencing errors with
insertion deletion errors uh quite rare
it's actually hard to see them in a plot
and uh this this profile is interesting
I think because it looks quite similar
to what one would expect from an alumina
platform and and that suggests that the
data from this G4 should be compatible
with uh software that is designed for
for Illumina data
uh and so to address that that or to
assess that question uh we decided to
perform germline variant detection using
the Google deep variant algorithm uh and
a model that had been trained
exclusively using Illumina whole genome
sequencing data so we took that model
and we applied it to our data set
without further training
and and this this slide shows the
results we have the metrics uh the the
performance metrics at 20x30x and 40x
Target coverage and and one can note
that the the performance both for sniffs
and indels is quite High uh again
without any further training suggesting
that the data is quite interchangeable
with with that from from the aluminum
platform
and then the last point I want to
mention is uh we also evaluated
performance over challenging genomic
features this include included
repetitive Elements shown at the left uh
homopolymers uh uh in the middle and
then short-handed repeats on the right
and we see excellent performance across
these different genomic features uh and
and and
um by the way this this study follows
the Paradigm uh used in the abrf Next
Generation sequencing study and I and I
just want to mention that you can really
tell from the performance on
homopolymers uh and shorthand and
repeats that this this data is quite a
bit different than what you'd expect
from something like semiconductor
sequencing where homopolymers are a
problem
so with that uh uh I'm going to finish
the talk and to summarize I described
how rapid sequencing and flexible
throughput are critical to reducing
turnaround times for research and
clinical applications I describe to you
in the ways in which we've been working
to improve
sequencing by synthesis to enable rapid
SPS and then I I hope I've convinced you
that one can achieve rapid SPS without
compromising data quality and the last
one I mention is that there's going to
be more data presented at the upcoming
hbt conference June 6th through 9th and
I'm leaving you here with an image of
the G4 sequencing platform it's a
benchtop sequencer so thank you for your
time and I'm really looking for I really
look forward to taking your questions